there is a hilarious report from Axios.
Now, it's not actually comedy.
It's it's serious, but it's hilarious in what
it's suggesting.
And the Axios report claims that Donald Trump
is actually getting ready to restart those
depraved he calls the MAGGA rallies.
I call them Korona rallies.
And it's all to keep the fight going against
supposed voter fraud that he claims allow
Joe Biden to steal the election from him.
As of right now, these are all baseless claims
without any evidence.
So the plan as per Axios is that the Trump
team will announce recounts in specific states
and then they will hold rallies in those states.
And the idea will be to fly in and really
raise money for the recounts, which are expensive,
and also try to kind of build public support
for those recounts and the idea that these
states were fraudulently stolen from Donald
Trump.
Now, as I told you yesterday in the story
about Trump's last scam, if you look at the
fine print of the fundraising that Donald
Trump is doing, I know that if you watched
yesterday's show, you know this.
But I want to repeat it.
If you look at the fine print of Trump's fundraising
for so-called recounts and fighting fraud,
the fine print is 50 percent of every dollar
you donate, not you, but the people who would
be dumb enough to do it.
50 percent of every dollar donated goes not
to fund the recounts.
Whoa, sorry.
I hit my mike.
They're getting a little too excited, but
half the money goes to paying off Donald Trump's
campaign debt.
So it's sort of like the final scam on the
tail end of what has been four years of a
scam presidency.
And the key states that they're looking at
are reportedly Georgia, Arizona and Pennsylvania.
Now, there have been reports that Team Trump
is not all on the same page about this.
Like, for example, we got a report two days
ago that Rudy Giuliani wants Trump to do rallies,
but that Trump's chief of staff, Mark Meadows,
and son in law Jared Kushner, want Trump to
concede.
But then there was a conflicting report that
Jared Kushner actually wants Trump to do rallies.
And Mark Meadows said something like, can
concession isn't even in our vocabulary, will
eventually know the truth.
According to this Axios report, everybody's
on the same page and they plan to get Trump
reelected.
Who the hell knows?
But if Trump does do these rallies, it would
not only be a scam, but it would be extra
irresponsible.
Given coronavirus.
You're not even running for anything at this
point.
Like we know that the rallies have been responsible
for hundreds and likely even thousands of
deaths while Trump was running a campaign.
At least he could say, I have to win for the
good of the country.
I believe him winning would have been bad.
And we know because Joe Biden did it, that
you can campaign safely, but at least he had
something he was running for.
This is now really just bottom of the barrel
trash like this is how you destroy a country.
He's not only refusing to concede, which is
not a legal issue.
Concession is merely a formality, but it makes
him look foolish and it's bad for the country.
But he's reportedly going to try to relitigate
the election through campaign style rallies,
the likes of which were already irresponsible
due to the pandemic before the election.
Now, if you look at the court judgment so
far to figure out, does he have a shot here,
the court judgment so far about voter fraud
have gone universally against Trump's campaign,
all of them saying there's nothing here to
move forward on.
There's just there's no there there.
But this now these rallies would be to get
to the court of public opinion, get crowds
of people where the focus is no longer vote
for me on Election Day.
The focus is we need money to beat Joe Biden
with lawsuits.
So if the reports were true that Jared Kushner
and Melania were telling Trump to concede,
it seems that those efforts have failed.
And we also shouldn't understate the impact
of these possible rallies on Trump's ego,
which at the end of the day, that's really
a huge role in what Trump decides to do each
day.
And a big piece of doing these rallies would
be ego and nothing else.
Will Republican senators even speak up and
call Trump out if he does this, or are they
going to remain quiet?
Because understand that as of just a few hours
ago, only four Republican senators have even
acknowledged that Joe Biden won and that Donald
Trump lost.
Those are most recently Susan Collins.
And we had Mitt Romney say Biden won.
We had Lisa Murkowski say it.
We had Ben Sasse say it.
It is absolutely pathetic.
And we're going to follow whether these rallies
become a reality and whether someone is able
to talk Donald Trump out of it, because ultimately,
that's what this may come down to.